good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I am a
total sucker for airport reunions and
because I've spent about a third of my
adult life and airports I've seen a lot
of them over the years but a couple
weeks ago I got to see well okay so this
is Sancho a waiting at the airport for
his wife and son he was born in Burma
also known as Myanmar and as a young man
he was taken from his community by the
army and forced to work on road
construction the conditions for forced
labour in Burma are horrible and it
remains a problem despite the steps
toward democracy the country has made in
the past decade beatings by soldiers are
common and deserters have been executed
persecution of religious and ethnic
minorities is also common and sasha is
both he is a Christian and a member of
the ethnic chin minority Sasha escaped
his forced labor crew in 2008 and
eventually found his way to Malaysia
where he registered as a refugee with
UNHCR but because he couldn't legally
work in Malaysia he had to live on the
margins of the social order then again
he couldn't risk returning home because
now he would be considered a deserter he
didn't consider himself lucky though to
find unofficial work in a restaurant
where he met Ted Ted a fellow Burmese
refugee who was a waitress in that
restaurant they fell in love and got
married but their refugee cases were
being processed separately the
bureaucracy faced by refugees is often
quite dizzying there are so many layers
of vetting and checking and only a tiny
fraction of people are ever approved for
resettlement also critically if you do
get approved for resettlement that news
can come at any time and when it does
you have one chance to take it or leave
it so in 2012 four years after escaping
to Malaysia Sasha a received permission
to come to the United States but because
Tet Tet's application was being vetted
separately she did not together they
decided that a should go partly because
they'd been told it was easy to reunite
spouses once one within the United
States so in December of 2012 with Tet
Tet 8 months pregnant Sachi left
Malaysia for Indianapolis there are more
than 13,000 Burmese refugees now living
here in Indianapolis so cha a joined
that community but he also joined the
broader Indianapolis community he found
a church and friends and a job he works
in a Clif Bar Factory but the very first
thing he did upon arriving was final
four family
unification quick pause to note that
refugee resettlement has not increased
u.s. crime rates in Indianapolis or
elsewhere in fact it is associated with
community crime rates dropping and also
there is little evidence that refugee
resettlement negatively affects
employment or wage and sources in the
video info below right so at the
beginning of 2013 Tet Tet is in Malaysia
caring for her baby some such are men
working when she can the family seems
certain to be reunited soon but delays
keep happening until finally in April of
Sasha a learns that his wife and son
will be coming to the United States
except there is a clerical error it
turns out that there are two Sasha AIDS
in a refugee database and Tet Tet has
been listed as being married to the
other one so the trip is canceled and
the process starts again at last in 2016
Tet Tet and such young men are again
approved for resettlement visas are
issued travel plans made and then comes
an executive order halting all refugee
resettlement into the United States for
at least 120 days Sasha a said he
started to wonder if he would ever get a
chance to see his son he'd prepared
everything for the kid to start school
in Indiana but now they had to wait
again with the refugee resettlement
program ever restart if so would people
already approved still be at the front
of the line or would it be 2014 all over
again but then as suddenly as the
executive order arrived a court ruled
much of it invalid and days later Tet
Tet and such' men were on a plane first
to New York and then to Indianapolis
Sasha a and I have both worked with a
local refugee resettlement organization
called Exodus and through them I was
invited to the airport for the reunion
and walking in I was so nervous would
there be another executive order a
different Court reaching a different
ruling no this time I got to witness the
best airport reunion as such I saw his
wife for the first time in over four
years and held his son for the first
time ever
no one can seriously think that
reuniting this family poses a threat to
the strength or the prosperity of the
United States but to be a refugee is to
have much of your life defined by powers
far beyond your control
yesterday a new blanket ban on refugee
resettlement was announced for at least
120 days meaning that many families
who've been praying for and told
to expect reunions like this one will
now have to wait now we can have and we
need to have a discussion about how many
refugees should be resettled in the
United States each year but a blanket
ban is a terrible way to start that
conversation instead I believe that
conversation must start by seeing
refugees as people with individual
stories who love their families and want
them safe Hank I'll see you on Friday
PS over at youtube.com slash 100-days my
best friend Chris and I are on a health
and fitness journey and on day 100 we're
going to run a 10k race you can sponsor
us all the proceeds will go to exodus
the refugee resettlement organization
here in Indianapolis link in the
doobly-doo below thanks bye